like watching 27 year olds say it's a
fad watching 36 year olds say like i
can't figure out a non-custodial wallet
like i don't want a coinbase like
they're scared of this the way parents
were scared of putting credit cards into
a computer
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
[Music]
vaynernation what is good we are back on
the podcast 2022.
i'm really not planning on doing too
many
interviews or episodes i'm kind of i'm
focused on befriends and vayner
x i think the speaking the books even
the content i'm down to the lowest
levels this week
in seven or eight years but when i get
an opportunity to do a show where i
think um
all of you who are listening are gonna
really enjoy the combo or have wanted to
see the combo
um i i've definitely heard through my um
through my uh navigating of the world
that people
wanted mark and i to interact or how
would we jam
um and i'm really excited that he's on
the show so i'm gonna let him introduce
himself and how he likes to speak
about himself
uh i'm curious myself and then uh we'll
get into a little bit of like book life
because he's a beast and then maybe just
shoot the [ __ ] on a bunch of different
stuff so
mark how are you
i'm great man it's great to be here i
can't believe we've actually never
talked before
the amount of peop you know there's
people like you and there's probably 15
other people over the last decade
that
you know how like it's almost like a
neighbor you have you've never talked
but you head nod
you know like i've always felt that i
had these kind of like people that ran
in similar circles shared friends yeah
and it was just
sheer serendipity that we weren't at the
same conference at the same event
that you know that that if we met seven
years ago at a south by southwest we
would talk 13 times a year versus not
once for seven you know like it's one of
those kind of things it's actually when
kobe bryant passed i actually promised
myself to slightly do a better job i've
done a little bit of a better job with
it but i'm such a
mad scientist in my lab
my family which is my real life and then
professionally my my laboratory and my
crew around my laboratory
cheer and and cheer and loot for
everybody on the outside
but spend so little time on it so i find
myself in these predicaments where
but but i i want to be a little more
thoughtful because i definitely feel
like i've always loved the way people
talked about you and that know you that
know me so i'm happy we're here yeah me
too man thanks um so quick quick intro
um i'm actually
from the blogging world i started
blogging in 07
actually discovered you back in like 09
2010
um
basically blew my career up going viral
on facebook and twitter back in the day
back when you kind of could go viral on
facebook and twitter
um
grew a massive audience millions of
readers each month parlayed that into a
publishing deal
books did super well have sold about 15
million books crazy numbers
how many have you written
uh
four
one self-published and then three
conventionally published
um the last one was i did uh i co-wrote
will smith's memoir with him that came
out a couple months ago
um and then what was the experience what
was the experience in in co-writing
you know i with him it was great um
i don't really aspire to be
uh a memoirist or or a ghost writer or
anything like that it's just he was just
he was cool enough and it was the whole
thing was cool enough to do he yeah he
and i really hit it off and and i think
did you come across brad haugen in his
world i know he's on the production
did that name i think he works on some
of the content side good friend of mine
anyway keep going um
but yeah i mean he he and i like
he was in the right spot in his career
to do the book
what i would call correctly you know
which is like actually open up and
actually get into kind of the ugly parts
of his life yeah um and then i think he
and i just like on a personal level our
our skills and
personalities complimented each other
really well so that ended up in i mean
i'm a 90s kid so yeah he's the [ __ ]
christian
i get suckered into things all the time
but honestly i mean it was such a great
experience but it's funny because i mean
now now that that book is done so well
you know i've talked to my agent she's
like you know other celebrities going to
want to do stuff and
people are going to reach out i'm like
you know i don't i don't know actually
like i don't know if that's something i
really want to focus on so it sounds
horrible
i if i think if you don't have the right
person or if there's not a good
chemistry i think it would be horrible
yeah it's kind of like the way i think
about vayner media like clients like it
actually is hard when i talk about
eating [ __ ] i don't think people really
understand like
like having when you're creative
having somebody two cooks in the kitchen
is incredibly challenging yeah it's not
that it's horrible i use that as a slang
term for man that you want to say
serendipitous and the person wants to
say you know by chance like you know i
i love my art of being a content
producer and being a businessman and
have absolutely with my father my
brother
you know especially when it's family
like that
had challenges when
you know i knew what i wanted to do was
right but i wanted to be empathetic or
have compromising capabilities or you
know yeah
so
and it's and it's
there obviously there were moments where
it's like there were certain things that
i felt should be in the book or certain
directions i thought certain chapters
should go and it's at the end of the day
it's his book yeah you know so it's good
for you to have like some because some
people
some people with no
leverage
yeah and juice
aren't great at having that humility you
came in
with some real front-facing consumer
leverage
you're you know obviously the reason so
many people
have brought
you up to me is because i say the word
[ __ ] so much and you obviously
you know
it's such a dumb dumb reason for people
to associate us but
it's it's incredibly fair actually i've
had more than a couple people ask me
through the years probably five which is
a lot if you think about it
hey are you pissed he wrote that book
like i'm like no i'm pumped he wrote
that book i was like i'm like you know
um
not from like that more like they just
really think there was a lot of
crossover of beliefs and then obviously
the word [ __ ] i think
actually just to go right into it
because there's so many marketing
branding content people
you have two books
with that
sorry i have a cough everybody um sorry
if this hurts the podcast a little bit
do you think
like
the brilliance of what tim ferriss did
i met tim around that time as well we
were all kind of running around those
you know yeah and he ran google adwords
to figure out which title would work
yeah you know obviously
you know ryan holiday and others i i
watch how people navigate
do you think the that in the title had
real impact no impact some impact on the
success
real impact for sure
i mean so that book you know you
mentioned the tim ferriss thing running
adwords
to kind of figure out four hour work
week
a lot of subtle art was very much market
tested through blogs yeah um so there
are you know you knew what was working
absolutely and that that that title so i
originally started writing that book
with a different title and then i wrote
an article called the subtle art of not
giving a [ __ ] and it went
[ __ ] bananas
and i was like oh [ __ ] okay maybe this
should be the book right um so there are
a lot of sections in that book that
grew out of
viral blog posts you know it's like i
know this works i know this like gets
people
yeah
um let me ask you a question um
[Music]
want the for the people listening what
is the one
two three sentence recap of the subtle
art of not giving a [ __ ] the 2016 book
that went bananas
uh basically it's
i always joke that that it's a book
about values but you know if i if i told
people it was a book about values nobody
would read it so
you got to put [ __ ] in the title and
kind of trick people into it but i mean
i mean you just you you do realize you
just completely in two sentences
recapped my entire career
i would argue
in two seconds here's the thing gary the
amount of [ __ ] i eat
here here's the thing man
and i think you you and i landed in the
spot for the same reason because you you
and i live
and breathe and eat and sleep
the the
online social media world and what you
quickly discover when you're in that
world is that there's an infinite amount
of stuff out there and so if you don't
figure out
val like if you don't discover values to
sort that stuff if you don't figure out
the principles of like this is what
matters to me this is what's important
to me and this is just crap that i'm
going to ignore
you're going to drown and
i i quickly just you know coming from a
self-help angle
i quickly discovered that a lot of my
generation's
problems a lot of the anxiety and
depression and stress that my generation
goes through it comes from just not
figuring out what those values are what
what are the sorting mechanisms in your
life and then when you don't have your
own you're grabbing to people's
grabbing to others you're completely
succumbing
to
um outside affirmation and the second
you are living for outside affirmation
it's game over yeah you know it's funny
i remember
seeing the book in the in the airports
because i'm always in the airports right
yeah and it grabbed me too like every
other human and i i remember feeling a
huge you know i i do to my community
famously talk about how little i read
but i remember feeling an incredible
kinship just on title
i also believe so much of the world's
problems is headline reading and making
assumptions
so
like i selfishly asked you that question
right now for my own self but i really
do believe
that
getting into a comfort zone of
understanding the following
do the people that know me the best
like me
and do the people that know me the least
have a chance of liking me or not liking
me is a very simple framework that can
help i mean i every day
i get accused of things that are not
true get negativity thrown at me and i'm
pretty positive
communicate like i'm trying to you know
but i have a style that i think rubs
people the conviction and the confidence
and the
you know the competitiveness like i get
it i understand why
it lands like that
i also think like alpha male energy
timing is a little awkward and i'm
empathetic to that those are macro
trends
but
everything that makes it palpable that
not giving a [ __ ] of course i care but
it's it's having a structure of
understanding no no but but
do the people that know me like me and
then as you get further away does it
still stay as good like
strangers
thinking that i'm a charlatan makes
sense 13 second clip on a video you know
that you know but
my mom thinking that that's devastating
and i think there's a lot
to that that i think a lot about well
it's it's also just the world that we
live in now right like it's we're
exposed to so many other people all the
time and so many other people are
exposed to us that it's it's
unreasonable to think that everybody who
comes across you is going to like you
but i think but i think there's a bigger
thing i love your thought on this i i
think we're also in the explosion
of
popular culture judgment
and and
pushing away as fast as we can any level
of accountability
so judging
is on fire
and accountability
everyone's running away from pointing
fingers super fun
popularized
point grabbing thumbs devastating nobody
wants to do it thoughts
absolutely one thing i wrote about
when the pandemic started was like
i feel like people have this addiction
to like
moral righteousness like it's
it's actually becoming a problem like i
think we should become
not less moral but like more amoral like
like withhold judgment on like what is
actually good and evil because it
because you're the judge when you're the
judge and the jury it's a game of
opinions outside of the things that most
common sense
nice human beings can agree on i don't
think anybody's on the side of murder
yeah of course but it's i i think you
know it's so easy to pass judgment like
moral judgment on people or groups of
people today and there's so little
repercussions and
i think that that is like we've just
kind of we've got this like crack
addiction to
moral righteousness as a culture well it
makes you feel better
when it feels meaningful it feels me but
there's no consequences yeah i think to
your point man we're going to really
nerd out on this
i i think it it's an indicator of more
collective unhappiness because i think
we're in a bigger game of outside
validation
yeah because when you're unhappy the
trigger of tearing somebody else's
building down
is an endorphin and a maybe not a dwarf
maybe i'm using is a hit emotionally for
you that helps you prop up in the short
term
yeah
and so
you know it speaks to you know it's
funny people will blame technology
social media things of that nature but i
think it really starts to your point
back to what you did in 16 it starts on
values like if parents
raise their children
in and i'm a capitalist and i'm an
entrepreneur but
but i love the game i'm not in it for
the lambo or the watch and if you're
teaching your kids that like it's all
about those things like we're going to
aspire to get a mercedes-benz
or
you know
you don't you gotta lose 15 pounds
because you don't look good or like all
these different things
everything you're doing to reinforce
that the outside world's judgment
matters
i'm the greatest beneficiary of a mother
who built me the reverse
yeah nothing else mattered but what
happened in our four walls and are we
nice to people and to each other and
call it a day
yeah
for sure man i actually i want to ask
you a quick question
very briefly at the beginning
that you're backing off on
content and uh
you are somebody who's created a
prodigious amount of content over the
years
and i've also been backing off on
content over the last year or two i'm
curious to hear why
your friends i i probably won't deliver
on my hyperbole in the beginning here
it's that
a new thing came in to my life
and you only have so many hours family
you know matters most then
professionally which is my great hobby
i gotta allocate a little piece to my
dad's business because i love him too
much so i gotta keep a little eye on
wine library wine text
and then i have a behemoth of a company
over a thousand employees globally you
know mexico city london aipac la new
york vayner x is now a big dog that's a
lot of work i'm the active ceo and i'm
like an active ceo like a ceo ceo so
that takes up a ton of time the only
other thing that took a time before was
garyvee right speaking books
content with v friends coming along it's
a really tricky one because not only do
i have to be the ceo operator it's a big
company and you're dabbling with nfts i
want to ask you about that because i saw
that somewhere
um
that's become a huge company jesus
christ it's kind of even hard for me to
like wrap my head around
but i also have to be it's not like
vaynermedia where i didn't have to build
the brand i just had to build a company
i mean i could have but i built it in a
b2b environment it was a whole unique
strategy
the friends i have to build
patient panda empathy elephant
you know curious coyote like i have
conviction [ __ ] i have like real work to
be done yeah
call it
you know dc comics marvel
disney transformers he-man so i'm a
great storyteller and marketer i believe
that but i have to put that energy now
into patient panda
and and you know an empathy elephant and
you know an adventurous astronaut not
into gary vee
yeah
that makes sense uh here's a good
analogy i've got to become more walt
disney than mickey mouse i've got to
become more vince mcmahon than hulk
hogan and the reason i used vince
mcmahon and walt disney is you still
kind they still were pop culture
and away like you knew who they were
they weren't the ceos of like ge you
know you knew who they were
but they weren't at the front of the
lights
yeah
why what tell me what's going on in your
nft stuff because you've seen that a
little bit in the social sphere
so i'm kind of
i'm a bit behind the curve to you but uh
you know i discovered nfts last year
basically like dropped everything you
know it start started neglecting
everything in my mind
are you are you like
are you like me that way like like
blogging when you first saw it you're
like this social that like you've got
that kind of you've been looking for
with that innate kind of you know
something's happening and it kills me a
little bit because it's it's you know
now i've got like a team of people i've
got like an online business you know
we're selling courses we're doing all
this stuff and like i feel bad now now
now it's like you know back in the day i
could just drop everything and be like
hell yeah nfts
um now i'm like having someone welcome
to my life yeah like you're getting all
my 3 30 meeting is with you know like a
toy retailer trying to do a huge deal
for the holidays and like 345 is like we
have this problem with the client our
project manager is not screwed you know
you're like oh man this is not yeah it's
hard yeah so i i'll use this opportunity
so this is this is this is exclusive and
that this is the first it's just been
publicly let's go
i don't get a lot of guests i'm excited
so uh i'm gonna bring
subtle art we're going to fractionalize
subtle art and bring it to the nft space
we're going to carve it up
into a thousand individual quotes and
[Music]
the way
the way copyright
agreements work with publishers is that
the publisher has his license to the
full book
but
if it's just a quote or if it's just a
paragraph or a section the author can do
whatever they want with it so
what we're doing is we're carving up the
book into individual quotes and
paragraphs
and then i'm basically going to
uh
uh give
creative commons license to those
individual quotes for whoever
purchases it so if you buy the nfp you
get the quote and then you could quote
unquote do what you want with the do
whatever you want with it yeah you're
buying it from you i can't give the
copyright you're giving the [ __ ] with
all sorts of stuff but you're getting
the creative commons rights kind of like
flickr was back in the day when everyone
was like whoa
it's
i'm not gonna mess with you um
so yeah super excited right so when i
buy a bunch of your most famous quotes
yeah and then make hoodies
and sell and make tons of revenue you
won't send me a letter
no
and you're gonna be like why is gary
able to sell more hoodies of my quote
than we were team
i wouldn't ask that about you but that's
not fair enough
but with some some random kid on the
street
so this this is cool i gotta get when uh
when are you doing this
uh looking at
late february early march or we'll keep
an eye on this where where should people
follow you look what's your twitter
because i'm sure that'll be the best
place to for this audience too
twitter is i am mark manson
i am got it what um in our ten minutes
here what what other things should
entrepreneurs go getters
kind of um what are some other things
that we can help people with or what do
you anywhere you want to take this like
a a fun story working with will
um an insight to what's working with you
on content right now because a lot of i
think we have enough crossover that
where you take it this audience will
like so whatever you want
well i'll say this i asked you the
content question because i mean for me
it's been a combination of
discovering web3 like it's
i mean i i've
i've
been in the crypto for many many years
but it always seemed it was like two
ponzi-ish
years ago it was all currency right like
i really understand the bitcoin thesis
and i'm still long at bitcoin because i
think the brand is too strong yeah and
nfts are so much more consumer what you
and i do it's not currency it's it's
this last year or two it's like oh [ __ ]
they're actually building stuff like
that let me give you an example yeah
nft project gets pumped
and it completely fails yeah like it
went up to 4 000 a piece and then in the
nft winter they're 88 bucks
i in 2026 i'm gonna buy 8 000 of them
and the ip and refurbish it
no different than what i did with
k-swiss
or what happens with brands all the time
with a [ __ ] coin from 2017
it pumps
we have the [ __ ] winter it's dead yeah
there's still an asset
with nfts
and a narrative that makes it very very
different than coins and i think that
i'm really excited about when we get to
that part of the story well if you think
about i mean like there's so many books
throughout history that
blew up after the author died you know
or like
yeah can you give us two or three
because i'm not educating that's if i
love that [ __ ] ah well like so like
scarlet letter nathaniel hawthorne like
is that true yeah or like moby dick like
[ __ ] armin melville like died broke
and alone like and then moby dick became
the great american novel after he died
you know so it's this sort of stuff
happens in publishing
and i'm super excited about nfts in the
publishing world as well because
it solves a lot of the issues actual pro
like practical problems the publishing
industry has and it's crazy too because
like doing this
are you currently i'm sorry interrupt
are you currently in a book deal
yes
how many more do you owe them one
yeah i my last book that just came out
the one i sold a drillion of because i
did an nft thing
um
i'm a free agent and i'm in the weirdest
spot
yeah i've had an incredible one with
harper collins who do you work with
harper as well amazing yeah
you don't work with hollis do you
uh
no i don't know okay my publisher is
hollis at harper business she's amazing
i find myself in a crazy predicament i'm
super happy there
yeah comfortable what can they offer you
that's the thing it's like what can they
offer you and and and i want them to
right because i don't i'm doing plenty
of my own stuff i'd like to have a
couple places where i have some
partnerships but the economics
are too extreme if my next book is an
nft and you get the book yeah
yeah it's crazy and it's it was
fascinating to me as well because like
when i first approached harper
about this this nft project i expected
tons of pushback you know and and i
expected them to kind of flip out and
i'd have to do damage control and to my
surprise like they're
i wouldn't say they're on board but they
are open
they are very open and curious like
they're they are watching very closely
well listen they they saw you know one
of their authors
sell 1.2 million books
in a day and you and i know what that
means i mean
you know i'm not i'm not the you know
i've done really well you've done really
well those are just uncomfortable
numbers crazy numbers
yeah that's crazy and those are moments
in time i think right now we're in
internet stock 99. that's the one thing
while everybody's listening just a quick
did that it's almost like a disclaimer i
always want to say we are the nft thing
is real it'll be here forever in a big
way so learn it
the individual nft projects
99 of them are in beanie babies mode
super hyped they're going to crash you
know what else was in beanie babies mode
internet stocks at 99. and that's what
happened but amazon and ebay were there
at seven bucks a share you could have
bought them you could bought amazon for
seven bucks a share before all these
splits they had it's insane yeah so
um
nonetheless uh
go ahead you were finishing a thought
but i was curious if you're debating as
a prominent
you know author like do you sign a book
deal or do you do it yourself now with
nft land
yeah i i honestly i i don't know i mean
we'll see how this launch goes we'll see
how the market goes i mean like you said
it's it's there's definitely a bubble
right now so like we'll hope to see how
things shake out but i could totally see
in like
two three years from now it being a very
very difficult question uh
answer um but what i was gonna say
before that is like i feel like i'm i'm
also in this weird like no man's land
because i'm so excited about web3 stuff
but
it also feels like it's still very
frothy and new and not completely
consolidated or figured out yet
meanwhile like on the web 2 side
on like the traditional social media and
blogging and everything everything just
feels like
i don't want to say dead but like
saturated right like it's the roi is so
brother it's you know it's the tail as
long as time the reason you and i in 07
and you did blogging the reason you
found me in 09
was
i would say the most frustrated i was in
my career in my entire career was 2005
to 2009
because i couldn't write i still can't i
can't write for a lick
yeah
and i saw blogging coming
and i'm like and you know and i had one
on kind of ecommerce and search
and i'm an email for sure yeah and i was
like
this is gonna be huge and i knew that i
was like on the sidelines with like my
helmet in my hand
and and literally the second
you know
the second oh i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
gonna i got my timer wrong oh three two
oh six oh four to oh six because the
second youtube came
i was on it so blistering fast
that's why my wine thing worked so well
because i was like okay i can use the
new thing and then obviously social new
thing and then every app on social but
you're right like it's gonna take the
next tick tock
to do anything in web 2
but even that is going to be a slight
alteration of what we've seen since o5
web 3 is like crazy new world which is
what we were learning about the internet
back in the day yeah it's web 2 it just
feels like you're taking the same
playbook
and applying it to new platforms exactly
over and over and it in africa it's a
real art like knowing the capture the
art of tick tock versus instagram is a
real art but to your point you're still
making a short form piece of content in
video form 100 and it's after 12 years
or whatever like it
you know it kind of you you kind of just
keep getting the same thing over and
over whereas like web 3 it just feels
like we're in like 3d chess no it's like
finding america
yeah yeah you know like like you thought
it was just europe
wait a minute
it's really like that it's our version
of that final thoughts give me you know
i don't i feel like we may have to do
this again because i want to extract
what are some
hot takes from a social commentator what
are you seeing out there what should
people think about what is a good what
were some good takeaways
hey gang hey gang keep keep an eye on
this whether it's literal like
ott shows or like pop culture or
common
emotional themes you're seeing and just
like takes
i i feel like
i feel like there's there's kind of like
a great moderation coming like i feel
like a lot of what felt so
unstable with social media and just the
news media in general throughout the
2010s i feel like it was a lack of
education on the user's end of like
people don't understand how
social media feeds affect
their
their moods their information
consumption
the way they think the beliefs that they
adopt and i think the the general
public's knowledge of how these things
work is catching up to like where you
and i were
five ten years ago and i think as that
happens we're already seeing it now
um
people are just learning better like
learning to to to turn off all the noise
and [ __ ] they're learning to
back off not hit the reply button so
fast yep um and i i i i see a kind of a
new boom of like independent voices
happening right now um i i'm like so
bearish on
traditional
east coast media right now it's crazy um
what's like what does that mean like
new york times in washington got it yeah
uh [ __ ] like that um
it's just i i just think they're
it's just a sinking ship um yeah i mean
i think all traditional media
needs a different model
they do they do it
it's not even about for everybody
listening it's not a left or right thing
it's funny when you said a great
moderation
i've been using a purple heart i've been
falling in love with the color purple
i've been i've been spending so much
time in this too bad my favorite color
is green but i'm gonna figure this out
i am completely convinced that what's
about to happen is purple i'm sorry you
and i we need to really actually become
friends we're clearly very similar
in a lot of ways i'm sure very different
others and those are the fun parts but
the world is so red and blue
yeah
and the answer is purple
and it's and some people and and
sometimes it's dark purple sometimes
it's very light purple but like it's so
clear
that we will die
and this is not even like from politics
like
you know like socialism or storming the
capital it just becomes societal it
becomes like operational it becomes your
day-to-day life it's it's everything
it's not j i mean it's most visible in
politics right but like but it's
everywhere it's everywhere like i i'm
i'm a big gamer i see in the gaming
community it's like the loudest most
insane
two percent of gamers are the ones that
you hear about all the time you know
it's like it's like the [ __ ] crazy
sports people are the ones you hear all
the time you know and it's like it's
it's our own fault for loving
rubbernecking yeah well and it's i i
hope slash feel that people are they're
smartening up to this and i think this
is why you're seeing like sub stack
takeoff you're seeing like
uh you know you there was a chart
recently of like joe rogan's numbers
compared to all like the
um
what do you call it cable news shows or
whatever and it's like
you know his audience is as big as like
the five biggest cable news shows
combined you know and it's like i mean
people are seven hundred thousand years
old that watch cable cut news like we
have to understand that by the way i i
think ageism is a problem i'm not
[ __ ] on 50 60 70 80 90 on i'm almost
50. [ __ ] you know euros i'm i'm [ __ ]
on the concept that the world's evolving
that i have unlimited friends who are 71
years old who know what stubstack is and
like read like all sorts of different
things and are just like and i have very
interesting friends who are willing to
watch both fox and cnn and this and that
and it's not even about like the
politics anymore it's just the formats
so so here's a thought for you i'll
leave you with this thought you know
when i was a kid
i used to make fun of my parents because
like we get like a vcr and my parents
didn't know how to program the vcr and
like my brother and i would figure it
out right and we would like make fun of
my parents like oh i'm so bad with
technology it was like a funny thing in
the 90s
to be an older person who was bad with
technology i think now it's potentially
like a social problem well and also i
think we we judge them so negatively and
then the nft thing fires me up because
all my 20 30 and 40 year old friends
became their parents overnight because
they're like i don't want to learn this
it's a jpeg like watching 27 year olds
say it's a fad watching 36 year olds say
like i can't figure out a non-custodial
wallet like i don't want to coin me like
they're scared of this the way parents
were scared of putting credit cards
into a computer like literally watching
20 and 30 year olds over the last 12
months become their 65 year old parents
has been one of the most joyous things
for me because i let them i trap them i
let them cause these are my friends i
let them i let them i'm like
that's the [ __ ] you used to make your
fun of your mom for yeah totally man
totally
technology we'll talk brother
congrats on all your success we will
cross paths again thanks for being on
the show thanks man great talking
you